this video is making the rounds it's
actually from several years ago and it's
from an episode of uh The Price is Right
and as a certain contestant appeared on
this show a few years ago and you may
recognize him
let's watch
spin the wheel they get to spin the
wheel but guess what you get a second
chance in this game first
so you know two prices already which is
a great thing 399 and 5.99 which one do
you want to keep
I'm Gonna Keep the 5.99. keep 5.99
something else up here is 5.99 you can
tell me what it is you get everything
I'm gonna say the soup
soup 5.99
it's pretty fancy it is
yes you got it that was the winner still
is a winner
Dylan nice job man
look at that uh we're gonna spin the
wheel right after this don't go away
folks
[Music]
my God
imagine being
[Music]
the father
imagine being a dad
and you're told that you know your son's
gonna be on Price is Right
and you sit down and you have a beer and
you sit down to watch more price is
right and this is what you see
imagine seeing your son
[Applause]
and I don't know how you go I don't know
how you
move on after that
well
but of course still all right turn off
please turn
uh
of course if Dylan Mulvaney's father
thought that this was the worst
embarrassment he was ever going to
suffer he had he was in for a rude
awakening as time goes on now the point
here though is that was a couple things
first of all this guy's been starved for
attention you know for a long time uh
has been uh begging for attention that's
what that's what all this is about
anyway but also
his
you note how his performance
as a woman
his performance as a woman as a quote-un
is identical to his performance as a
flamboyant homosexual on Price is Right
and this is a performance as well
because like no no human being actually
acts like that in real life so this is a
before it's like it's a it's an affect
that he's putting on
um but it's exactly the same
because that's all that a woman is to
the left that's the left's vision of
Womanhood that's all a woman is a woman
is a flamboyant gay man in a dress
so you've got flamboyant gay man and
then you and then you take that same
flamboyant game and change nothing about
him
put a dress on him that's a woman
that is truly how they see it that'll do
it for this portion of the shows and
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]